Act now.
ABOUT THE BORDER TODAY.
>> IF THEY DID.
>> WHAT DID YOU LEARN?
>> A LOT.
>> IS THERE A CRISIS AT THE
BORDER?
STEVE: PRESIDENT B BIDEN ARGUES
THE SURGE AT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER IS NOT A CRISIS.
HIS DENIAL COMES AMID REPORTRTS
PROTECTING 117,000, 30% HIGHER
THAN THE MOST WE HAD.
THE ADMINISTRATION DOESN’T HAVE
ENOUGH BEDS AVAILABLE.
DAN CRENSHAW, GOOD MORNING TO
YOU.
IT IS NOT A CRISIS AT THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
ALL THESE PEOPLE BEING RELEASED
BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT INTO
THE UNITED STATES SOMETHING
LIKE 6% OF THEM HAVE COVID-19
AND WE CAN’T STOP THEM.
>> THE USUAL EUPHEMISM, IT IS
NOT A CRISIS, IT IS A
CHALLENGE, NOT A CAGE BUT A
STRUCTURE AND THIS IS THE
TRUTH.
DEMOCRATS AND JOE BIDEN WANT
THIS.
IN THE PAST THEY USED TO SAY WE
WANT BORDER SECURITY BUT WE
DON’T WANT TRUMP’S -- WE
SHOULDN’T BELIEVE THAT.
THE AGREEMENT STOPPING THE
BORDER CRISIS, RIP UP THOSE
ASYLUM AGREEMENTS.
AS BIDEN WAS GETTING
INAUGURATED.
HERE WE COME.
THEY REINSTITUTE THE PRACTICE
OF CATCH AND RELEASE IN YOUR
SHOW BUT LINES OF PEOPLE, YOU
KNOW WHO THEY ARE CUTTING IN
FRONT OF, LEGAL IMMIGRANTS, MY
STEPMOTHER IS A LEGAL
IMMIGRANTS, LEGALLY IMMIGRATED
TO THIS COUNTRY, DID IT THE
RIGHT WAY.
WHAT IS INFURIATING ABOUT THE
COVID-19 POSITIVE CASES, US
CITIZENS HAVE TO GET A NEGATIVE
TEST BEFORE COMING BACK INTO
OUR COUNTRY, ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
OVER US CITIZENS.
STEVE: ACCORDING TO ACTIO’S,
JOE BIDEN WAS BEING TOLD IT IS
NOT A CRISIS, THEY NEED 20,000
MORE BEDS.
SO MANY KIDS AT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER ARE STARTING TO RELAX
THE BEDDING OF WHO CAN SPONSOR
THAT IN THE COUNTRY.
THEY ARE SO DESPERATE TO GET
PEOPLE INTO THE COUNTRY, SOME
PEOPLE IN THE STORE THAT GRIFF
WAS TALKING ABOUT, THEY TOLD,
IN MARYLAND, NEW JERSEY, AND
WHO ELSE KNOWS, WHO KNOWS WHERE
ELSE, EXPOSURE TO COVID-19 WHEN
THEY ARE STILL INFECTED.
>> WHAT IMMEDIATELY NEEDS TO
HAPPEN IS REINSTITUTE THE
MIGRANT PROTECTION PROTOCOLS,
THE REMAINING MEXICO POLICY.
THIS SINGLE-HANDEDLY DROPPED --
WHAT IT DOES IS A PORTION OF
THE ILLEGAL CROSSINGS ON ANY
GIVEN DAY GETS SENT BACK TO
MEXICO CITY ARE CLAIMING
ASYLUM, CLAIMS ARE BOGUS, THEY
ARE NOT BEING PERSECUTED IN ANY
WAY BUT IT CREATES A
DISINCENTIVE TO CROSS BECAUSE
THEY KNOW THEY WILL BE SENT
BACK TO MEXICO.
WHEN YOU SAY IF YOU CROSS, WE
WILL GIVE YOUR BUS TICKET
ANYWHERE YOU WANT NO MATTER
WHAT COVID-19 YOU HAVE.
THERE IS A MASSIVE INCENTIVE
FOR THOUSANDS MORE PEOPLE TO
COME ACROSS AND A DRAG CHILDREN
WITH THEM AND THE WORST PART
ABOUT THIS IS THIS ENCOURAGES
CHILD TRAFFICKING.
I TALKED TO A LOT OF BORDER
AGENTS WHO SEE THESE KIDS
RECYCLE OVER AND OVER BECAUSE
ALL THEY KNEW WAS THEY NEEDED A
KID.
STEVE: GOVERNOR ABBOTT
YESTERDAY, ALL THE RESTRICTIONS
ON A STATEWIDE BASIS AND I KNOW
MAPS AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
YOU MENTIONED IS ANTILOCK THE
LEGISLATION TO END THE SHUTDOWN
DURING THE PANDEMIC.
IT IS CALLED THE END LOCKDOWNS
NOW ACT.
PRETTY CLEAR WHAT THAT IS ALL
ABOUT.
>> LOCKDOWNS DON’T WORK.
STUDY AFTER STUDY AFTER STUDY
HAS SHOWN THIS.
WE HAVE A YEAR’S WORTH OF DATA,
THE MOST RECENT OUT OF STANFORD
AND IT CONCLUDED THERE IS NO
ADDITIONAL BENEFITS TO
HOMEOWNERS, NO ADDITIONAL
BENEFITS TO CLOSING BUSINESSES.
EXTREMELY HIGH COST ACTION, NO
BENEFIT.
COVID-19 HAPPENED.
IT IS THE PANDEMIC.
I DON’T KNOW WHY THE LEFT CAN’T
UNDERSTAND THIS.
THEY ARE IN LOVE WITH LOCKDOWNS
AND MANDATES, THEY BELIEVE IT
IS SAFER BECAUSE THEY ARE
ANTI-SCIENCE, THE LEFT IS
ANTIPSYCHOTIC, THEY DON’T
LISTEN TO THE DATA, THEY DON’T
LISTEN TO THE SCIENCE.
IT IS NOT FEDERAL OVERREACH
EITHER.
IT HAS FOR RELIEF MONEY TO A
REOPENING PLAN.
IT IS IMPORTANT WHEN YOU HAVE
CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA, NEW
YORK BEING DESTROYED BY THEIR
GOVERNMENT, THEY HAVE NO
REOPENING PLAN AND NO LIGHT AT
THE END OF THE TUNNEL, THE
SECOND PART OF THE BILL SAYS IF
THE PRESIDENT CANNOT
UNILATERALLY LOCKDOWN THE
COUNTRY AS JOE BIDEN SAID HE